un chapiteau de la pépinière plein à
craquer des applaudissements à n'en plus
finir et deux concerts exceptionnels de
sarah vaughan ont enthousiasmé le public
du festival de jazz de nancy angie pvt
hier soir un des événements de sa
huitième édition en accueillant des plus
grandes stars du jazz de suite la
chronique quotidienne de jean-pierre
delgado et patrick germain
non pas de photos s'il vous plaît de
nombreuses paires delgado vous pêche au
sahara vaughan ça continue oui non faut
dire effectivement qui hier soir c'était
un petit peu difficile pour pour nous
télévision et aussi pour nos confrère
photographe parce que c'était chacun
dans son coin sur les côtés de la scène
pas devant un homme sans égal
on pouvait faire ça que pendant la
première ou la deuxième chanson j'étais
quand même
sabrina parce que l'année dernière on
était déjà habitués tous les ans il ya
une soirée un petit peu comme ça les
coûts m en face à dernière c'était de
chasse il faut s'abstenir c'est sarah
vaughan
difficile aussi pour les pour les
admirateurs de sarah vaughan parce que
fin du premier concert n'y a pas eu un
bis et les parties tout de suite comme
ça on n'a jamais revu savané pas
forcément quand même des cris des pleurs
et des grincements de dents dans
laquelle est avec 20000 dollars alors si
le dollar aujourd'hui 8,80 compter
compter combien samson d'immigrants pour
deux concerts ça fait rien on va quand
même regarder un extrait de madame sarah
vaughan
et
institut désinsérer de ce mercredi c'est
orchestre orchestre avec proto l'insee
avec viser new york
mr burns qui sont la seule l'essonne
enseignants d'ailleurs de 7,2 ce
programme cnjp ville vienna art
orchestra alors tout de suite on va
regarder un petit extrait de la balance
qu'on a enregistrées en cours de soirée
avec le vienna art orchestra
et